Kim Kardashian and Kanye West expecting  their third child any day now I'm gonna  freak out a source confirms to eat see  the couple's surrogate who is pregnant  with their third child a baby girl has  not given birth yet the little one is  due any day according to the source and  Kim and Kanye are quote fully prepared  and can't wait to bring their baby home  but don't expect to see the birth of  their baby girl on Keeping Up with the  Kardashians the source says the pair  will be in the delivery room without TV  cameras that is hard for me et has also  learned  Kim and Kanye have not chosen a name for  their second daughter yet et sat down  with Kim in November where she opened up  about how four-year-old daughter North  and two-year-old son st. reacted to  finding out they would be welcoming  another sibling to the fam I'm really  honest with my kids they are excited  you